[موسيقى]
أعتقد أن لدى
جميع الكائنات وعيًا واحدًا ،
لذلك عندما تتواصل مع الحيوانات والطبيعة ،
فإنك تحصل حقًا على واحد مع نفسك ، فإننا
نتعثر في حياة المدينة بشكل صحيح ،
ونريد جميعًا نوعًا من الهروب إلى
الطبيعة ونعم إنه مجرد شعور جميل
[موسيقى
] لقد ولدت وترعرعت في دبي
ولم أتخيل مكانًا مثل هذه
دبي لا يفشل في إدهاشك
طوال الوقت الذي تعرفه
وإنشاء مثل هذه
الأماكن الجميلة والساحرة للناس للحصول على مثل هذه
التجارب
[  الموسيقى]
الشهيق والزفير وإطلاق الذراعين
مما يمنح الكتفين بعض التراجع قليلاً ،
لقد قمنا بدورة يوجا هذا الصباح ،
كل شخص وجد مكانًا
على طول
لولب الأرضيات ، لقد بدأت للتو في أخذ
بعض الأنفاس العميقة اللطيفة العميقة التي أتنفسها
المدربة فقط تجلس على
القمة وتتدفق مع الفصل بصوتها المريح
وكل
شخص يذهب إلى حالة معينة
تكون فيها مدركًا لما
يحيط بك لأن الطيور تفعل
ما تفعله وهم  نقيق
حولك وأنت تركز حقًا على
فهم أنفاسك يأخذ أنفاسًا عميقة كبيرة
وشهقة في
الأنف والزفير من خلال الفم.
يبدو أن كل شيء
يبدو وكأنه يتلاشى وأنت حاضر
في الوقت الحالي وتجرب
حقًا وتأخذ كل شيء
إذا كنت تحب اليوغا ، ولا أعتقد أن هناك
مكانًا أفضل للقيام بذلك